donc si j'ai décidé d'aller jusque là et
puis d'aller jusqu'au bout et puis
devenir également ce matin
c'est parce que voilà j'ai pas envie que
ça se reproduit j'ai pas envie non plus
que pour les autres mères je vous dis
qu'ils m'ont qui m'ont adressé des
messages et qui subissent aussi voilà
des violences verbale ou physique voilà
je crois qu'il faut que ça change et on
s'aperçoit que dans les différentes
propositions de loi qu'il y a eu enfin
je le vois rien pour l'instant on en a
bougé donc mon souhait puisque certains
dit que j'étais devenu un symbole ma foi
voilà si je peux au moins terminer
cette carrière politique
en essayant d'avoir fait quelque chose
et puis d'avoir fait bouger les lignes
pour justement l'avenir et notamment
pour les élus parce que on s'aperçoit
quand même que les contraintes sont
quand même de plus en plus importantes
et qui est-ce qui est à ce contact avec
nos concitoyens c'est avant tout c'est
le maire qui arrive là en premier et
c'est lui qui doit à tout prix défendre
toutes les décisions de l'État et on
sait très bien que c'est quand même pas
simple à tout à l'heure j'ai cité en
tout début Lausanne je pense que ça va
être difficile voilà d'annoncer à
certains citoyens que voilà leur terrain
on peut plus et puis constructive on
peut plus rien faire déjà on s'aperçoit
que dans ces différentes lignes de de
projet de l'État
est-ce qu'il y a de la communication
bien pas forcément moi je sais que au
niveau de du pays de Ré avec mon
collègue mère Jean-Michel Brar le maire
de Pornic on avait fait une conférence
de presse parce que on arrêtait pas
d'entendre on en a nos communes mais
arrêtez de bétonner arrêter de bétonner
dans les centres-villes parce qu'il y a
des immeubles qui se construisent pour
essayer d'expliquer justement nos
concitoyens on applique on applique la
loi voilà
on a essayé également moi je l'ai fait
au niveau de mon bulletin municipal tout
un dossier